[Music]
our eight news now investigators have
new information on the A's possible move
from Oakland to Las Vegas we've all been
watching and waiting to see if lawmakers
come up with a 395 million dollars the
A's are asking for from the state and
County eight news now investigator Kyle
Payne joins us in studio with more
details Kyle Kirsten as usual money is
at the center of the drama in Carson
City where any day now we expect to hear
how all these Logistics with the A's in
Clark County and the state will shake
out
a source intimately familiar with these
negotiations tells 8 news now that the
A's deal will look nothing like the
Raiders deal when they moved here from
Oakland
in that case Clark County raised hotel
room taxes to pay for the bond for
Elysian stadium in this case the county
will take the taxes earned from sales in
and around the ballpark to pay off or
service those bonds that's because
Governor Joe Lombardo says he won't
allow any new taxes to fund the A's new
stadium and that Stadium most likely
will take over the land where the
Tropicana hotel now stands but the eight
news now investigators also learned that
the previous land deal the eighth struck
just a couple weeks ago to take over
land adjacent to the Trop owned by
Station Casinos was partly done in
because Las Vegas's powerful Culinary
Union wouldn't support that site because
some of the Station Casinos aren't
unionized the source also tells 8 news
now that the A's are certain to ask the
state to waive the live entertainment
tax Which tax on nine percent to the
price of concerts and sporting events
and exemption lawmakers have allowed to
make it more palatable for the Vegas
golden knights and Raiders to come to
Las Vegas
Kirsten I did reach out to Red Rock
Resorts which owned Station Casinos in
The Culinary Union for comment The
Culinary Union referred me to public
statements they've already made over the
last month or so Red Rock had no comment
back to you all right thank you Kyle now
the A's have the lowest payroll in
baseball the worst record than a few
years since they made the playoffs and
out of all the MLB teams they have the
fewest number of fans attending